we have a subreddit discussion forum
where you can join 26 000 other viewers
and listeners
and discuss politics respectfully you
can find it at davidpakman.com
reddit few notable posts i spotted this
morning one is a user asking whether we
are going to get to 4
000 daily deaths from the virus after
christmas or new year's
i've said before that i believe the case
peak is coming very soon
and that the death peak is slightly
behind that and that then we are going
to
start seeing warming weather and
vaccinations
starting to have an impact probably by
late january early february so i believe
we are almost at the pandemic peak
unless something goes very wrong
um i hope we don't get to 4 000 daily
deaths we are regularly seeing
3 300 3 400 now more than a 911's worth
of deaths every day
um it's it's conceivable we will get to
4 000.
i'm hopeful that we will not uh because
that would be an absolutely
uh a tragic tragic milestone but it's
not inconceivable
another user of reminding us that new
york has enacted automatic voter
registration this is a topic we've been
discussing for a very long time
the idea that in order to vote you need
to do something beyond simply
being a citizen is antithetical to the
way many voting systems are set up in
other countries
undocumented immigrants by their nature
can't vote because they're not citizens
uh this is not something that uh is
unique to the united states and yet we
have this process here which serves only
to dissuade people from voting or
prevent people from voting
which is even though you could vote you
can't vote
unless you register to vote some states
allowing same-day registration
many not allowing it new york state has
enacted automatic voter registration
the details are still being sifted
through
but that is very very good news
more states should do it and then lastly
because we're wrapping up here before
the holiday
we got a holiday greeting via the
subreddit holiday greetings to david and
pat with much thanks
thanks for maintaining continued
surveillance of the events of this past
year
including the horrendous coveted
pandemic and the equally disgusting
trump and republican machinations
revolving around the election as someone
who has increasingly tuned out much of
the news i nevertheless have great
respect for those who can face what's
been going on
and report and comment about it it's not
an easy task
knowledge can be disheartening but also
empowering
hope next year ends on a higher note for
all of us but whatever the case
hope the pacman show will endure
a beautiful message and you can join the
discussion
at davidpakman.com
reddit